totalement terrifiant et effrayant
l'éclair et le phénomène naturel le plus
mortel et le moins résolu sur terre
au commencement de l'humanité il
représentait la colère de Dieu il
frappait de terreur notre imagination et
changer la vie de ceux qu'il avait subi
les éclairs frappent sans discrimination
et sans prévenir une centaine de fois
par an des hommes au hasard en sont les
victimes certains tentent le diable en
chevauchant une chaîne de montagne
élevée où en prenant des photos dans un
endroit désert
mais les autres deviennent des victimes
dans leur train quotidienne comme se
rendre à la poste ou préparer un repas
quand l'orage arrive il est préférable
de se mettre à l'abri seulement parfois
il est impossible de s'abriter on ne
sait comment ni pourquoi l'éclair frappa
un endroit pourtant couvert cela reste
inexpliqué
la grande escalade dans la chaîne de
montagne dans la Sierra Nevada s'appelle
le mont Whitney un des points culminant
des États-Unis
tous les ans des milliers de randonneurs
se rendent à l'est de la Californie pour
gravir ses 4418 mètres d'altitude
[Musique]
le matin du Samedi 14 juillet 1990
Michael Watson et son beau-frère terrine
à bourse se préparer un franchir le
sommet du mont Whitney ils avaient
décidé de grimper jusqu'en haut dans la
journée et d'effectuer une boucle afin
de regagner le refuge juste avant la
tombée de la nuit
le bulletin météo de la station des
gardes forestiers de igno annonçait
qu'il y avait un léger risque
d'après-midi orageux comme souvent en
été
tandis que Michael était rit atteignait
les 3300 mètres les sentiers boisés
cédaient la place à achemin difficile de
pierre et des rocailles et l'air sera
réfié
meilleur forme que moi et dans les
passages difficiles je m'appuyais sur
lui mais nous devions maintenir notre
allure jusqu'au sommet sinon nous
aurions dû rebrousser chemin au
croisement d'un chemin à leur retour ils
arrivaient à l'école ou ce qu'il vit à
l'Est et à l'Ouest leur parut
consternant
nous avons observé que le ciel était
recouvert de nuages certains d'entre eux
annonçaient la pluie mais la plupart
étaient assez loin
mais ce que Michael et Terry ne pouvait
voir c'était si nuages orageux menaçants
de l'autre côté de la montagne ils ont
donc poursuivi leur marche bientôt au
détour d'un chemin de pierre la cime fut
en vue atteindre le sommet s'avérer
maintenant chose facile encore 150
mètres à monter mais le temps changeait
rapidement
ça s'est passé tellement vite un peu
comme si le nuage nous était brusquement
tombé dessus il était à peine 5 heures
du soir la température chute très vite
la pluie et la grêle se sont abattus sur
les pierres nues les randonneurs
cherchèrent un abri
pendant 10 bonnes minutes nous avons
regardé partout recherchant le moindre
recoin pour nous abriter mais à cette
altitude cela ne court pas les rues il y
a bien les éboulis des morceaux de
rocher éparpillés de tous les côtés mais
rien d'assez grand pour s'abriter et se
protéger à cette hauteur
un éclair frappa un morceau de granit le
seul abri que Michael a pu trouver était
une légère saillie au milieu des rochers
nous étions pratiquement entièrement
exposé imaginez-vous cherchant un abri
dans un parking ressemblant à un désert
alors quand nous avons trouvé ce petit
coin de rocher cela nous a semblé le
paradis un véritable feu d'artifice
d'éclair striait le ciel sombre
Terry et Michael sous équipés pour un
tel temps était trempé jusqu'aux os
pour se protéger de cette pluie glacée
Terry sortit une couverture de survie de
son sac à dos
il prirent chacun un coin de la
couverture pour la maintenir devant le
surplomb rocheux
on avait un peu plus chaud et nous
étions assis depuis à peine 30 secondes
que cette idée m'a traversé l'esprit
cette couverture était fabriquée avec
une sorte de matériaux métallique la
seule chose dont je me souvienne était
la phrase de Michael me demandant la
notice de la couverture pour voir si
elle était contre-indiquée par tant
d'orage
c'est juste à ce moment que l'éclair a
frappé réduisant la couverture en
miettes et plaquant les deux hommes
contre les rochers
je me souviens avoir pensé est-ce la fin
du monde qu'est-ce qui se passe tout
autour
et puis j'ai réalisé que je ne rêvais
pas petit à petit j'ai retrouvé mes sens
et je me suis entendu pleurer et j'ai
entendu pleurer terry
était allongé il tremblait saisit de
convulsions comme dans une sorte de
crise
alors j'ai compris ce qui s'était passé
nous avions été électrocutés
j'ai regardé le sol et j'ai vu que mes
jambes tremblaient elles aussi
Michael avait l'impression que son corps
se consumait sous une chaleur terrible
il a rapproché ses jambes de son buste
et tenter de rouler hors des rochers
pour découvrir d'où venait ce feu pas de
flamme mais sa peau avait pris une
couleur brillante et pourpre et il avait
visiblement les mains et les doigts
brûlés
de Space mais de tremblements et un son
épouvantable sortait de sa bouche comme
le cri primaire
du rocher et lui a mis une paire de
lunettes de soleil dans la bouche pour
éviter qu'il ne s'étouffe avec sa langue
j'ai pensé que c'était le plus gros
problème jusqu'à ce que brusquement tout
s'arrête le bruit a cessé tout mouvement
avait stoppé il était juste
éry avait cessé de respirer Michael
pratiqua la respiration artificielle sur
le corps inanimé de son beau-frère
il m'a bien fallu 15 minutes avant que
je réalise qu'il ne revenait pas à lui
pendant ce temps les éclairs n'avaient
pas diminué il continuait de craquer
tout autour de moi et parfois je
ressentais les fourmillements de la
décharge électrique qui s'enfonçait dans
le sol
a essayé d'envoyer de l'air dans les
poumons de Terry quelques minutes plus
tard Terry ouvrit les yeux
j'ai dit Thierry nous avons été frappé
par la foudre nous devons dégager d'ici
et sa réponse immédiate fut que s'est-il
passé j'ai répété Terry nous avons été
frappé par la foudre
Terry avait une vertèbre cassée des
brûlures sur le visage les mains et les
chevilles
Michael ladde à se remettre sur pied et
a soutenu son corps affaibli il
confrontèrent leur opinion pour savoir
s'il cherchait à notre abri ou s'il
rebrousse le chemin était juste une
question de temps avant que la foudre ne
frappe de nouveau
j'ai vu la zébrure d'un éclair devant
nous la décharge nous passait le long
des jambes et c'est ce qui a dû se
produire
je pense qu'au moment où Mike a pris la
décision il avait de loin la charge de
l'expédition il a jugé que nous devions
redescendre
ils ont ta mère leur descente aussi
rapidement que possible et puiser et
grelotant il dévalèrent les pierres
enneigées et prirent des raccourcis
difficiles à travers les sentiers
je parlais sans ménagement atterri pour
le faire avancer je lui disais Terri
veux-tu encore revoir ta femme et tes
enfants
je pensais vraiment que si j'avais pu me
reposer un instant j'irais mieux et s'il
n'avait tenu qu'à moi je serais resté et
nous ne serions jamais revenus de la
montagne
ayant survécu à deux éclairs fulgurants
Terry et Michael craignèrent ensuite de
mourir d'hypothermie finalement après
quatre heures de lutte il trouvèrent un
camping
les campeurs enroulés les randonneurs
gelés dans des sacs de couchage et leur
donnèrent de la soupe chaude
la nouvelle de randonneur accidentée
avait été diffusée sur les radios des
autorités du comté de l'ignore
une équipe de secours se dirigée vers la
montagne et vers minuit ils atteignent
Michael et Terry
ils nous ont ausculté afin de voir s'il
n'y avait aucune fracture et brûlure
sérieuse et si nous étions suffisamment
d'aplomb pour passer la nuit au camping
finalement nous avons pu rester la nuit
sous la tente
le lendemain matin Teri a été aéroportée
à l'hôpital Michael a choisi de rentrer
seul
je repensais à cette randonnée on était
près du sommet et on a dû faire
demi-tour dans des conditions atroces je
sentais que j'avais vraiment besoin
d'évacuer toute cette tension par ma
propre volonté
même si la plupart d'entre nous sommes
conscients de notre vulnérabilité au
beau milieu d'un orage et d'éclairs
impressionnants nous ne réalisons pas
combien les scientifiques ont encore
beaucoup à apprendre au sujet de ces
éclairs mortels
on ne comprend pas exactement comment il
frappe la Terre on ne comprend pas non
plus comment cette connexion se fait
quand il frappe et pourquoi pas plus que
nous savons quand il démarre d'un nuage
Martin human est l'un des chercheurs les
plus renommés au monde sur les éclairs
pendant 25 ans il a essayé de comprendre
ses détails mystérieux autour d'eux les
chercheurs croient que les éclairs sont
une réaction électrique apportée par des
déséquilibres de courant dans les
nouvelles orageux
l'éclair est une version amplifiée de la
petite décharge électrique que vous
ressentez quand vous vous êtes frotté à
une couverture et que vous touchez une
poignée de porte c'est une décharge de
quelques millimètres l'éclair mesure 16
80 parfois 100 km de long
chaque année de plus en plus de
randonneurs sont confrontés à cette
force impressionnante de la nature trop
tard souvent pour sabriter ils sont
blessés ou tués pourquoi sommes-nous si
vulnérables
les gens sont frappés par les clercs
soit parce qu'ils sont sur un point
culminant ou soit parce qu'ils sont
connectés à l'objet le plus élevé autour
d'eux en étant les plus hauts dans un
champ où au sommet d'une montagne ils
offrent une connexion possible avec le
sol la personne se tient debout et le
circuit est complet
à haute altitude trouver un abri dans
les montagnes et presque impossible
Michael estéri pensait être protégé par
un python rocheux mais l'éclair peut
frapper et faire mal même indirectement
quand il frappe dans les montagnes une
personne peut essayer de se cacher
derrière des pierres mais quand il pleut
à torrent et que les éclairs déchirent
le ciel tout autour du rocher le courant
traverse l'eau puis est conduit par elle
dans les moindres trous de ce rocher
vous n'avez ainsi pas beaucoup de
protection
déterminer à finir la randonnée qu'ils
avaient commencé Michael et son
beau-frère Terri retourne mon Whitney et
partent à l'ascension du sommet
le temps est clair le ciel dégagé mais
il se souviennent des éléments déchaînés
quand vous faites l'ascension d'un
sommet il existe certains risques non
calculés mais vous tentez votre chance
vous savez que vous n'avez aucun
contrôle sur la nature il faut seulement
l'accepter
je me sentais comme la première fois il
y a fort longtemps
j'étais vraiment arrivé à apprécier le
temps qui m'était offert sur la terre et
en profiter au maximum vous ne savez
jamais quand votre fin arrivera
l'électrocution elle-même dure une
fraction de seconde mais les dégâts
occasionnés durent toutes les vies
[Musique]
un nombre impressionnant de gens
survivent à une électrocution parce
qu'il ne reçoivent pas la décharge
maximale sans en être totalement sûr des
scientifiques pensent que la décharge
passe le long du corps et non à travers
lui mais qu'est-ce qui peut endommager
le système nerveux et changer les
fonctions cérébrales
et ainsi que la découverte une
Californienne il n'existe aucun remède
[Musique]
par un froid matin de septembre en 1991
Joyce Hodge quitte à sa maison de San
josé en Californie pour se rendre à son
travail de gros nuages noirs commencer à
assombrir le ciel matinal
au travail Joyce se prépare une tasse de
thé puis ayant mis ses écouteurs elle
s'installe à son bureau
son pied droit posé sur un petit
radiateur électrique métallique Joyce
regarde la pluie frapper les carreaux
ses collègues se plaignaient de ce temps
épouvantable alors que Joyce était
fasciné mais alors que la tempête
semblait s'atténuer elle s'est sentie
mal à l'aise
l'éclair a été si intense que
vous pourrez crépiter comme s'il se
trouvait dans le bureau et le tonnerre à
secouer tout le bâtiment
brusquement un éclair à illuminer le
ciel tandis que le tonnerre a grandi en
même temps le bâtiment avait été touché
la décharge électrique de l'éclair
voyageant à travers les lignes
téléphoniques atterrit dans les
écouteurs de Joyce le courant attiré par
le petit radiateur électrique métallique
lui a aussi traversé le pied
immédiatement Joyce a ressenti de la
douleur et ses sentiments
j'ai pensé que j'avais une crise
cardiaque j'ai commencé à ressentir une
vive douleur dans le buste et le bras
droit consciente que quelque chose
n'allait vraiment pas Joyce a voulu en
parler à sa patronne mais elle était
incapable de sortir un mot cohérent
plus tard elle m'a dit avoir eu
l'impression que je parlais chinois elle
ne comprenait rien de ce que je lui
racontais son état empirant son bureau
appela une ambulance
en voulant me lever pour me rendre à
l'hôpital
je me suis rendu compte que je ne
pouvais plus tendre ma jambe droite
parce qu'à chaque fois que j'essayais de
la redresser
c'était comme si l'on m'enfonçait un
poignard dans le cœur
brusquement alors qu'elle était
transportée par l'équipe médicale sa
douleur a disparu elle fut envahie par
une sensation de chaleur et de bien-être
[Musique]
c'était comme une lumière éclatante
j'avais l'impression d'être dans un
nuage c'était chaud et radieux et je me
suis sentie totalement en paix
cette étrange sensation de calme fut
brève à l'hôpital les médecins ne
trouvèrent pas la cause de cette douleur
intense
beaucoup d'entre eux ne prennent pas
trop au sérieux les plaintes des gens
électrocutés parce que les dégâts
internes de l'électrocution ne se voient
ni dans les examens standards ni à la
radio les spécialistes eux pensent que
les dommages ne peuvent être vus car ils
se situent au niveau cellulaire
notre corps entier travaille par
impulsion électrique soit vos nerfs ou
les muscles ou votre rythme cardiaque
tout est électrique il n'est donc pas
déraisonnable de penser que même si vous
transmettez de minuscules charges
électriques à travers votre corps vous
ne pouvez provoquer des changements
réversibles ou irréversibles dans les
enzymes et les mécanismes cellulaires
les séquelles nerveuses ne peuvent être
signalées au cerveau que par la douleur
l'irritation ou un comportement
inhabituel de la personne
il ne restait pas une seule partie de
mon corps qui n'avait pas été touchée
j'avais mal partout aux yeux et je ne
pouvais plus me coiffer car même mes
cheveux me faisaient souffrir marcher
était devenu impossible je rampe je ne
pouvais plus marcher
après deux jours d'hospitalisation Joyce
est rentré chez elle sa douleur et sa
souffrance restée est inexpliquée
au fil du temps à ces mots physiques
Joyce dit ajouter des changements dans
son comportement alimentaire une soif
constante puis un assèchement de la peau
de la somnie et une paire de cheveux
[Musique]
je ne pouvais dormir sans ventilateur et
parfois mon corps était si brûlant que
j'avais l'impression d'être chauffé à
blanc mais actuellement particulièrement
du côté droit j'ai des problèmes osseux
je les sens comme des glaçons cela fait
mal vraiment trop mal et il n'y a rien à
faire pour me soulager
mentalement Joyce se bat avec d'autres
symptômes l'affaiblissant comme la perte
de mémoire et des changements dans sa
personnalité
avant je faisais partie de la chorale de
ma paroisse
j'enseignais le langage des signes et je
faisais le catéchisme
maintenant j'ai tout oublié je ne me
souviens ni des signes ni des versets de
la Bible ni d'aucune chanson
j'aimais la compagnie je me sentais plus
sereine au milieu des gens que toute
seule
maintenant pour être apaisé Joyce passe
le plus clair de son temps dans son
jardin à s'occuper de ses fleurs et de
ses légumes que la négligence d'un
voisin abîmé son jardin Joyce a été pris
d'une monstrueuse scolaire une autre
séquelle de son électrocution
je pensais alors que la seule chose qui
pourrait me calmer serait de le tuer
je suis resté dans cette étape pendant
trois jours je ne dormais plus j'ai
pleuré trois jours j'étais totalement
déprimé par cette situation qui n'était
que broutille
et pendant tout ce temps je ne rêvais
que d'une chose comment tuer mon voisin
le plus proche
finalement la colère de Joy se retombée
la laissant effrayer par ce qui était
devenu son fonctionnement de pensée
très je me rendais compte que c'était
fou mais durant ce laps de temps rien ne
me semblait logique ma raison n'existait
plus et cela est extrêmement dur pour
moi vous comprenez
on ne sait pas très bien pourquoi
certaines personnes survivent à une
électrocution
même si la radioactivité de l'éclair est
six fois plus importante que celle du
soleil beaucoup d'énergie se dissipent
dans l'air avant d'atteindre le sol
peu de choses sont connues des séquelles
à long terme sur le corps humain
le docteur Méric Cooper est l'un des
chercheurs de l'université d'Illinois
Chicago spécialiste des effets médicaux
de ces électrocution
elle a enregistré les dommages causés
par les éclairs sur l'homme depuis 20
ans
la chose la plus difficile pour les
victimes et de ne pas être cru si vous
êtes touché par un éclair la plupart du
temps vous serez observé sur l'extérieur
de votre corps et non à l'intérieur et
pourtant vous n'êtes plus le même votre
charge électrique ne fonctionne plus
correctement et votre cerveau a changé
de directive un autre chercheur
Marguerite Primo et neuropsychologue à
l'école de médecine de Chicago
elle affirme que le système nerveux et
les vaisseaux sanguins sont
particulièrement vulnérables à
l'électricité parce qu' est en liquide
ils offrent un passage facile pour le
courant
nous savons aussi que le courant entre
dans la tête par les orifices tels que
les yeux les oreilles le nez et la
bouche et qui a-t-il entre vos yeux et
vos oreilles votre cerveau aussi est
évident que le courant traverse le
cerveau même si la personne ne semble
pas reliée à quoi que ce soit par sa
tête
utilisant une technique nouvelle et
controversée
l'électroncéphalogramme quantitatif
qeg le cerveau de Joyce est analysé
les résultats ont été décryptés par le
neurologue Fernanda
dans le cas de Joyce les parties du
cerveau ne fonctionnant pas correctement
sont frontal ainsi que son côté droit
cela pourrait affecter son jugement en
lui influant des pulsions incontrôlées
et une mauvaise orientation de sa
mémoire spatiale
Margaret primo pense que ce type de
dégâts du cerveau pourrait expliquer la
colère subite de Joyce
c'est une perte apparente de la
personnalité je ne pense pas que ce soit
un nouveau trait de personnalité n'ayant
jamais existé chez elle elle devait
l'avoir en elle mais auparavant elle le
maîtrisait et le contrôle
qui ne se souvient même plus de son âge
ni qu'autrefois et l'aimait les éclairs
une guérison complète lui semble
utopique
les nombreux médicaments prescrits au
fil des ans lui ont offert des
soulagements mais pas le vrai remède
le système nerveux central ne guérit pas
celui en périphérie se détériore encore
quant à la moelle épinière aucun
changement ainsi puisqu'il semble y
avoir des dommages permanents dans le
cerveau lui-même elle ne guérira pas
avec l'avancée de la recherche le
docteur Cooper pense qu'un jour de
nouveaux médicaments pourront apporter
la guérison au dommages neurologique du
cerveau subies par les victimes de
l'électrocution mais pour l'instant la
guérison dépend des amis des médecins et
de sa volonté à survivre
longtemps j'ai regretté de ne pas avoir
été tué je voulais mourir mais
maintenant j'ai fait le point et cela va
mieux pour moi les choses sont normales
en moyenne chaque seconde des centaines
d'éclairs frappent quelque part dans le
monde les chances d'être électrocuté par
l'un d'eux sont de 1 sur 500 000
incroyablement une femme l'a été non pas
une fois mais trois fois
à une heure de l'après-midi le 15
septembre 1983 Linda Cooper finissait
son travail
le temps à fortnite avait été orageux
toute la matinée mais juste au moment où
elle s'apprêtait à effectuer quelques
courses le ciel menaçait de virer à
l'orage et à la pluie
la Floride est une région à tempête tout
le monde le sait mais on n'en tient pas
compte je devais me rendre à la banque
et à la poste aussi et j'ai pris le
risque et j'y suis allé Linda quitté la
banque et se rendit à la poste elle
s'arrêta sur le bord du trottoir juste
devant l'entrée j'avais juste un petit
collier et quelques lettres à poster et
besoin d'acheter des timbres une banale
course à la poste alors que je marchais
et m'apprêtais à franchir la porte
l'éclair a frappé
j'ai cru qu'une grenade avait exposé à
mes côtés la lumière était la plus
éblouissante lumière que j'ai vu et le
bruit assourdissant
un éclair avait frappé le mât devant le
bureau de poste et ensuite Linda elle
avait été projetée sur le sol
[Musique]
je crois qu'il a traversé le mât et m'a
frappé sur la tête parce que j'ai un
endroit sur celle-ci qui semble plus
fragile il y a une légère coupure qui
montre que c'est par là que le courant
est entré dans mon corps
Linda soumise au même symptômes dont
souffre les autres victimes fatigue
chronique douleur perte de mémoire et
maux de tête persistant malgré ces
dommages et sa peur linda est heureuse
malgré tout d'être encore en vie
[Musique]
cet accident a changé ma vie et je sais
que c'est définitif
coup de temps avec ma fille adolescente
je dormais alors que j'aurais pu faire
tant de choses avec elle cela a
bouleversé ma version antérieure des
choses et me fait apprécier chaque
instant de la vie comme un cadeau
Linda a passé les 10 années suivantes à
reconstruire sa vie en partie détruite
par la foudre et dans la crainte des
orages je faisais très attention aux
éclairs je ne téléphonais pas je ne
faisais pas la vaisselle ni la lessive
en fin rien de ce qui n'était pas
recommandé d'effectuer par temps Dora en
mai 1993 Linda discutait au téléphone
avec sa fille lorsqu’un orage digne de
la Floride éclata
d'un seul coup un courant électrique
passe par le téléphone me frappe sur le
côté de la tête et ébranle notre maison
j'ai hurlé et lâché le téléphone mon
mari est arrivé en courant frappé pour
la seconde fois Linda était effrayée
plus qu'elle l'a été blessée
j'ai ressenti les mêmes fourmillements
que lorsque vos nerfs bougent tout seul
et je restais là en état de choc en me
disant oh non mon Dieu s'il vous plaît
oh non pourquoi
cette fois-ci la douleur et la fatigue
n'en durer que quelques mois
l'année suivante Linda et sa famille
voyager dans Caroline du Sud ou les
orages ne sont pas réputés violents
quand l'orage a éclaté le 11 juillet
1994 l'expérience avait appris à Linda
ce qu'il fallait faire ou ne pas faire
je ne devais pas faire la lessive ni me
servir du moindre ustensile électrique
le dîner cuisé dans un récipient et
Linda T est assise à la table de la
cuisine en train de travailler quand
elle décida de préparer un dessert
ma famille aime les desserts ils adorent
la gelée aussi je prépare cette entremet
et le place dans le réfrigérateur puis
j'ai voulu laver le récipient je me suis
dirigée vers l'évier et lorsque j'ai
tourné le robinet l'éclair a craqué puis
le courant est passé le long de mon bras
cette fois-ci je l'ai senti mon bras
était en feu je suis allé vers le
réfrigérateur j'ai ouvert le congélateur
et j'ai mis le haut de mon corps et mon
bras dedans et je suis resté là
essayons de me calmer
linda est restée assise frigorifié
jusqu'à ce que son mari la trouve deux
heures et demie plus tard
[Musique]
je l'ai juste regardé et me suis mise à
pleurer chérie lui ai dit elle m'a
encore frappé il m'a pris ma serrer en
me demandant mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
subissant encore une fois traumatisme et
nausées linda est resté avec beaucoup de
questions sans réponse notamment une
pourquoi
pourquoi certaines personnes
attirent-elles la foudre
quelqu'un qui est frappé plusieurs fois
par la foudre et seulement victime du
hasard car rien dans l'individu ne
laisse voir quelque chose de spécial il
n'y a rien de commun entre ces victimes
ornik elles sont peut-être plus souvent
dehors que les autres
qu'elles étaient électrocutées plusieurs
fois ou juste une fois les victimes sont
souvent réticentes à parler de leurs
expériences
elles se sentent embarrassée et sont
fatigués de ne pas être crus
une association appelée victime
internationales de la foudre des
courants électriques a été créé en 1987
pour aider les survivants à raconter
leur histoire
j'ai été électrocuté trois fois la
première fois je vivais en Floride
c'était en 1983 à ce moment là je ne
connaissais personne qui avait été
frappée par la foudre mais maintenant
j'en côtoie je m'aperçois que nous
ressentons tous les mêmes symptômes il
arrive aussi que la foudre frappe lors
des sports de loisirs en plein air
beaucoup de golfeurs entre autres furent
électrocuté lors des compétitions
annuelles
un homme se trouvait dans son allée
nettoyant les vitres de sa camionnettes
lorsque la foudre la touche
la foudre est arrivée et a frappé ma
camionnette comme je faisais conducteur
avec mon véhicule à cause de l'eau elle
est descendue le long de mon côté gauche
ce qu'il faut retenir des paroles des
survivants c'est leur expérience et
surtout écouter et apprendre de leurs
erreurs
le plus important pour moi est
d'apprendre aux gens à ne pas faire
n'importe quoi en cas d'orage ne pas
jouer au golf par temps orageux il y
aura bien d'autres jours pour jouer ne
travaillez pas dans les champs ne vous
promenez pas sur la plage sous les
éclairs soyez prudent avec la foudre car
elle est puissante et peut vous blesser
voir vous tuer
la fureur de la nature a alimenté
pendant des siècles les mythes
fantastiques et les légendes même si la
science peut expliquer beaucoup des
phénomènes observés dans le ciel
beaucoup croient en cours au mystère et
à une puissance divine derrière les
éclairs un photographe amateur pense
qu'il a saisi cette présence
surnaturelle sur un cliché
comme beaucoup de photographes qui
chassent l'éclair Steve Melvin a une
relation particulière avec les orages
déchaînés
alors que les chasseurs tirent sur les
animaux les Trophées des photographes ne
sont qu'un clichés un photographe
attendra souvent longtemps avant de
capturer la photo unique celle qu'il
recherche et qu'il exposera chez lui
au fil des ans avec son appareil Steve a
pris beaucoup de photos devant sa maison
de Madison dans le royaume
le soir du 12 juin 1989 était lourd et
humide
un orage menacé par l'Est avant sa
progressivement par le lac guerrier
qui veillant regarder la dernière météo
télévisée annonce à la tempête se
préparer pour ce qu'il pensait être une
série d'éclairs exceptionnelle
j'ai pensé que je devais installer deux
appareils photos et deux trépieds et
tout posé sur les hauteurs puis
commencez à chronométrer le temps entre
les éclairs pendant que l'orage se
déplacerait
il a noté l'avancement de la tempête
toutes les 15 minutes
à minuit elle est apparue sur l'horizon
juste devant sa maison
l'éclairs que Steve attendait déchirer
maintenant le ciel noir
j'avais l'impression de voir un éclair
unique qui me semblait magnifique je me
suis dit c'est peut-être ma nuit Steve a
mis son appareil photo en batterie dans
la bonne direction il a ouvert
l'obturateur et à regarder les éclairs à
travers la lentille
il a ensuite avancé la pellicule pour
une nouvelle photo l'éclair se montrait
il apprécie le déclencheur à nouveau
[Musique]
brusquement il s'est passé un truc
bizarre dans l'air comme une sensation
de vide
le poil de mes bras se hérissait je
savais à ce moment-là que ce n'était pas
normal
Steve a voulu tout ranger rentrer au
plus vite mais il ne pouvait pas bouger
c'était comme si j'étais cloué au sol
les cheveux dressés sur la tête
j'entendais des chemins comme un steak
sur le grille juste un
et ce fut la dernière chose que j'ai
entendu
le chemin a été suivi immédiatement par
une nouvelle étincelle blanche et
lumineuse
tout ce qui se passait autour de moi
était incroyable inexplicable comme si
j'avais été drogué un sentiment de calme
et de paix j'ai commencé à pleurer je ne
savais même pas pourquoi ce n'était pas
la peur mais pourtant quelque chose de
grave arrivait tous les problèmes et les
ennuis tout ce qui m'était arrivé
semblait s'être envolée
Steve se souvient ensuite qu'il était
couché sur le dos les éclairs zébrés le
ciel autour de lui et la pluie lui non
dès le visage
il a attrapé son appareil photo et à
foncé chez lui la sacoche de l'appareil
semblait fondue
j'avais très peur j'avais réalisé qu'il
avait dû se passer des choses mais
j'étais encore en vie je suis émerveillé
par tout ce qui m'est arrivé
l'appareil photo abîmé a été démonté par
un technicien le film qui n'avait pas
été détruit fut enlevé et développer
le développement s'est révélé un tirage
comme Steve n'en n'avait jamais vu
auparavant
quand j'ai regardé cette pellicule pour
la première fois c'était un peu comme si
les éclairs venaient des nuages cela
ressemblait à des fantômes dont on
distingue presque les corps vous pouviez
voir deux trous et teste les yeux une
partie d'un bras de jambes un torse
c'était effrayant
pendant des années Steve a lutter pour
trouver une explication aux émotions
qu'il avait ressenties et est-ce comme
elle est approche de la mort la photo
prouve dit-il la présence d'une force
spirituelle
ces photos ont capté des images que
personne ne peut expliquer un phénomène
hors du commun
le chercheur Martin Oman ne sait que
penser de ses photos il y voit des
éclairs mais la façon dont Steve a pris
la photo les montres à l'envers
c'est une photo d'un nuage qui forme un
éclair il y a le canal principal vers le
sol et ici le bras fourchu et là des
stries mais la question est qu'est-ce
que c'est et je ne connais pas la
réponse
en fait tout le monde a sa propre idée
de ce que cela pourrait être
une fois j'ai eu le point de vue d'un
médium qui m'a dit que j'avais
photographié ma propre âme c'est
impossible de dire ce qui s'est
réellement passé certains disent que
c'est l'eau sur la lentille ou que
l'appareil photo a subi un trop
longtemps d'exposition
le météorologue et pasteur André Bernier
croit que ses opinions peuvent être
plausibles toutefois il reste toujours
les spéculations sur les mystérieux des
saints de Dieu les voies de la
Providence dit-on sont à pénétrables
j'ai examiné attentivement la photo afin
d'y chercher tout d'abord une
explication rationnelle mais que dire de
cet étrange forme humaine que l'on
distingue il n'existe pas d'explications
claires bien sûr il serait vraiment
intéressant et plus simple de croire
qu'il y avait quelque chose déterré de
spirituel saisi par la pellicule ce côté
éternité je doute que nous le
connaissions un jour mais c'est bon de
le croire
certaines des expériences physiques de
Steve sont similaires de celles d'autres
personnes ayant approché de près les
éclairs il décrit ses cheveux je
dressant sur sa tête comme un
avertissement qu'un éclair va frapper
descend sur le sol il vient à proximité
de la surface et semble regarder autour
de lui dans un rayon de 45 mètres
cherchant l'endroit où frappé
les arbres les pointent les pôles
puissants les cheveux des gens qui se
dressent tout est un conducteur
potentiel et lorsqu'il le trouve il
frappe
Steve a aussi expliqué que lorsque
l'éclair a frappé le sol il n'avait pas
entendu de coups de tonnerre mais juste
un chemin une autre indication qui
prouverait qu'il était vraiment proche
du poids d'impact le tonnerre est causé
par un réchauffement extrêmement rapide
de l'air proche du noyau de l'éclair il
se propage partout sur 45 à 90 km aux
alentours et puis les ondes se replient
sur elles-mêmes tout ceci s'effectue en
un millième de seconde et produit à la
fin une seule onde sonore qui est le
tonnerre si vous êtes à l'intérieur de
ce premier son tout ce que vous
entendrez sera un petit teintement un
craquement ou un crépitement
ce qui reste inexplicable et ce
mystérieux sentiment de paix et de calme
ressenti par Steve Joyce aussi l'a vécu
ainsi que le randonneur Michael Watson
c'était vraiment tentant de fermer les
yeux et de me laisser porter par
l'instant par cette sensation de douceur
mais j'étais persuadé que si je
m'abandonnais à cela c'est exactement ce
qui se passerait pour moi ce serait la
fin
maintenant Steve Melvin n'est plus
prudent quand il chasse les tempêtes
avec son appareil photo il espère qu'un
jour viendra ou quelqu'un lui expliquera
ce qu'il a photographié
[Musique]
la puissance de la foudre frappant
directement peut-être fatal mais peut-on
réellement guérir d'une seule petite
décharge
[Musique]
presque tous les survivants à une
atteinte de la foudre souffre de graves
problèmes médicaux quelques-uns
seulement affirment guéri
[Musique]
en juillet 1993 Betty galvano est tombé
et ses fracturé la hanche
pour replacer l'os correctement 10
broches en acier ont été implantées dans
son fémur droit et dans l'os il y a
pendant un an elle s'est déplacée avec
un déambulateur plus avec une canne sa
langue guérison était un grand
changement dans sa vie habituellement
active
j'ai toujours été une personne très
active et subitement je me
retrouveraisduite à ne pas pouvoir faire
grand-chose chaque fois que je me levais
pour marcher ma jambe me semblait lourde
comme un sac de sable alors je restais
là debout à faire la grimace puis je me
disais allez je vais faire cette balade
Betty fervente catholique a demandé à
ses amis de prier avec elle pourra
prendre rétablissement
j'ai toujours prié pour ma jambe
la pénible de m'a genouiller
le samedi 11 juin 1994 Betty a assisté à
la messe de l'après-midi et c'est
confesser
puis elle a regagné la maison de son
fils à Fort l'odeur d'aigle chez qui le
séjournait
aux alentours de 5 heures du soir Betty
se trouvait dans la cuisine en train de
couper les brocolis dehors la tempête
approchée la fenêtre était ouverte mais
les stores baissés empêchait Betty de
voir les sombres nuages orageux
[Musique]
brusquement un coup de tonnerre terrible
éclata et il m'a semblé que la cuisine
entière était éclairée
cela m'a ébranlé de partout le couteau a
volé dans les airs et les brocolis se
sont éparpillés dans la cuisine je tombe
à la renverse et immédiatement je
ressens comme des millions et des
millions d'aiguilles qui me transperce
le pied ma jambe était tout engourdi et
je ne pouvais plus bouger mon genou
le mari de Betty se précipita pour la
prendre dans ses bras et la porter sur
le canapé et lui massa la jambe jusqu'à
ce que l'insensibilité disparaisse
[Musique]
tandis que j'étais étendue je regardais
par la fenêtre je voyais le jardin et
une partie d'arc-en-ciel c'était
tellement beau que je me suis dit que
Dieu me protégeait je me sentais
vraiment entre les mains de Dieu
et lorsque enfin j'ai pu me lever et me
tenir sur mes jambes cette sensation de
lourdeur dans ma jambe avait totalement
disparu au contraire je la sentais
pleine d'une toute nouvelle énergie
dans sa fille est rentrée de son travail
le soir et là tout de suite remarqué un
changement dans l'attitude de sa mère
j'ai observé une énorme différence dans
sa façon de marcher
elle ne se plaignait plus c'était
tellement fou car je savais combien elle
souffrait elle aurait pu se tuer sous la
douleur
est entré par la fenêtre ouverte ou par
l'évier jusqu'à ses pieds nus le
lendemain il s'est rendu à l'église pour
raconter au prêtre ce qui s'était passé
[Musique]
il a émis une sorte de rire et m'a dit
que j'avais été assommé par l'esprit et
c'est bien le genre d'explication à
laquelle je crois pour cette guérison
[Musique]
est-ce le courant électrique de l'éclair
qui a soulagé la jambe de Betty ou une
sorte de Placebo une excuse pour
expliquer sa croyance dans sa guérison
presque miraculeuse
médicalement d'après les experts une
éventualité de guérison est toujours
possible d'autant qu'il reste énormément
de facteurs inconnus au sujet des
éclairs de plus les décharges
électriques sont parfois utilisées pour
guérir des dépressions ou des fractures
mais dans le cas d'une guérison
accidentelle les spécialistes doutent
il existe des histoires autour de gens
sourds ou aveugles guéri par la foudre
après avoir été frappé par la foudre
cela engendre inévitablement des dégâts
au niveau du système nerveux il se passe
des connexions et des déconnexions du
système électrique et je ne pourrais pas
dire que ce genre de miracle est
impossible mais parler des événements
séparément et plus facile que dans leur
globalité
j'ai appris une chose en écoutant tous
ces gens garder l'esprit ouvert afin
d'être capable de les écouter et de
s'imaginer ce qu'ils avaient pu subir en
général la foudre a plutôt tendance à
les rendre malades plutôt que bien aussi
merci mon Dieu s'il rend la guérison
possible mais je ne conseillerais jamais
à quelqu'un de se tenir sous l'orage
pour guérir tous ces mots
pour en savoir plus sur tous ces
mystères entourant les éclairs des
scientifiques du monde entier
poursuivent leur recherche dans un
laboratoire d'une université en Floride
il crée des éclairs artificiels en
envoyant des fusées dans les nuages
orageux qui se forment souvent dans
cette région
il est difficile d'étudier les éclairs
car il n'éclate jamais quand vos
instruments sont prêts à enregistrer des
mesures d'où l'avantage de ce programme
éclair sur mesure avec ses fusées
reliées à des conducteurs nous forçons
les nuages à produire un éclair que nous
conduisons où nous voulons
étudier les survivants de la foudre est
évidemment plus délicat parce que des
sujets humains ne peuvent pas être
exposés à des décharges électriques même
contrôlées
pour les chercheurs c'est le mystère qui
les entoure qui leur fait vouloir les
écouter avec un jour il puisse
comprendre pourquoi certains survivent
et d'autres pas
chaque cas d'électrocution est différent
tout dépend de la force en charge
électrique de l'éclair ou des vêtements
portés par les victimes ainsi que le
fait qu'ils aient été secs ou mouillés
il n'existe vraiment aucune explication
rationnelle et je pense qu'il coulera
encore beaucoup d'encre avant que l'on
soit capable d'expliquer ces phénomènes
c'est cette mystérieuse photo qui
m'intéresse car ce n'est pas toujours la
même représentation on a l'impression
que ce sont deux éclats différents et on
ne sait pas pourquoi et c'est ce côté là
que je veux étudier plus à fond
la première étude sérieuse sur les
éclairs a démarré il y a 200 ans quand
Benjamin Franklin a fait voler son
fameux cerf-volant
avant les éclairs étaient toujours
entourés de pouvoir mythologiques
les Indiens d'Amérique pensaient que
c'était les ailes d'un oiseau divin qui
fabriquait le tonnerre les Grecs
croyaient que les éclairs étaient la
colère de Zeus quant au latin il s'en
servait pour prédire le futur
soit craint soit vénéré la foudre a
toujours eu sa place dans les esprits
sur la terre entière les éclairs
frappent environ une centaine de fois à
la seconde il existe une sorte de base
communicant entre les décharges qui
montent et celles qui descendent
quelles sont les charges exactes quel
rôle joue-t-elle sur le système
biologique en frappant la terre que se
passe-t-il au niveau du champ magnétique
de la Terre nous ne savons rien
exactement
même s'il semble que nous vivions en
parallèle avec les clairs il a sans
discrimination aucune interrompue des
milliers de vie soit quand vous
gravissiez des sommets à pic ou marcher
tranquillement dans votre ville ou que
vous châssiez les tempêtes produisant
ses éclairs fascinants
les conséquences sont multiples et
toutes aussi tragique des traumatismes
émotionnels des dommages neurologiques
et des questions sans réponse
mais un monde sans éclair n'est pas
envisageable nous serions privés du plus
extraordinaire spectacle sont et lumière
que seule la nature peut nous offrir
mais aussi de la puissance naturelle la
plus inexpliquée
[Musique]